[Music]
now who better to discuss uh the year in
politics in 2023 than the spectators
chairman Andrew Neil who joins us now
along with uh The Spectators columnist
the great Rod little um hello to you
both thank you happy Christmas Merry
Christmas Happy Christmas to you both
uh Andrew I'll start with you um let's
start with the recent and at home um
rishy sunak uh Rwanda bill passed last
night in the House of Commons um but
it's a bit of a sorry State for the Tory
party is it not uh when this was seen as
a victory for sunak um and actually it
was just the avoiding of a of a huge
defeat was it not I think I file sorry
State under a British understatement I
think uh yes he does live to fight
another day by winning the vote you know
shock horror government with majority of
80 wins vote um but it doesn't change
very much I mean the the dominant
feature of British politics in
2023 has been the failure of the
conservatives in general and Mr sunk in
particular to move the dial uh that
labor lead of around 20 points just
stays solid it doesn't matter what the
Tores do uh they try a relaunch in the
summer they try a new pitch at their
conference they have an Autumn statement
uh they try to put more life into the
illegal boats into the boat people
policy none of it moves the dial it is
almost the exact opposite of what
happened when John Major took over from
Margaret Thatcher uh in 1990 when John
Major took over of course there hadn't
been musical chairs of leadership she'd
been there for a 11 years she was by
then unpopular but John Major for a
while saw an uplift in the polls for the
Tories it moved the dial this time it
hasn't and I think that Mr sunak is
haunted by the fact that he's not a new
leader that's taken over from a
longstanding leader he's a new leader
that's taken over from David Cameron
Theresa uh May Boris Johnson Liz truss
uh and with all that game of musical
chairs it would seem to me that the Tory
credibility is shot to hell and things
won't be any different next year either
and Andrew I mean at the beginning of
the year I remember tor's talking quite
a lot about sunak still having a narrow
path to victory at the next general
election do you think that path is now
non-existent it's close to non-existent
I mean I'm always reluctant to uh Say
Never because we do live in a very fee
political age uh and things can change
very very quickly uh I mean i' look at
America far from Donald Trump being
under pressure now in Iowa his lead is
increasing in Iowa and he'll romp home
in the Iowa caucuses on January the 15th
so we we we live in in in a time when
suddenly it can all just go hell to
Skelter but sitting here with the
knowledge we have now again the news as
we uh uh record this of the British
economy actually uh
declining uh in October there's no sense
of economic momentum there's no sign of
living standards returning to growth
inflation for some Curious reason is
more stubbornly High here than it is in
any other major economy so again I don't
see what happens that moves the dial and
if I was to really come down to one
thing I I would say it's it is in the
end this other than this absurd game of
musical chairs that the T have been
treating the country too I regard Richie
sunik as a decent man a decent man a
competent man uh a bit technocratic but
nevertheless a patriot has the best
interests of the country heart works
very very hard but for some reason he
just doesn't have that X Factor that
leadership quality that allows you to
build a return and instead it's really
what Jim kakin said in 1979 when he was
beaten by uh Margaret Thatcher he was
told in the runup to the election hey
Jim there is still a Pathway to Victory
for you and he basically said n there
comes a time when it's over uh the
country's made up its mind and the other
lot should be given a chance and for
good or ill I think that's exactly where
we are
now well Rod I suppose thank God for
Britain and the British left that they
have the hugely charismatic
Kia starma uh leading the labor party to
a general election Victory next year
yeah I
mean Andrew summed it up beautifully I
think uh I mean it is very similar to
what we were saying this time last year
nothing has changed very much I mean and
what was implied in what what what
Andrew was saying was uh nobody voted
for rishy sunak you know um the British
people didn't vote for richy sun the
British people didn't vote for for Liz
Truss the British people didn't vote for
Theresa May uh and there is so there's
this immense weariness with the
conservative party um which will not go
away and there is nothing you can do to
move the dial on that um there was one
suspicion that perhaps if inflation came
down and wages began to rise a little
bit which is always a a difficult
Paradox to pull off uh that that perhaps
the position would be better for the
conservative party but there is also the
feeling amongst those who particularly
up here that there's been a sort of
Palace coup uh while there's no great
love left for Boris Johnson uh the
people up here who voted overwhelmingly
for for the conservative party in 2019
now see that the conservative part is
back on its usual uh liberal remainer
trajectory and have want to have nothing
to do with it it's very odd because it
seems that nobody nobody actually at all
in any of the parties AP from mine
obviously uh wants to have anything to
do with the red wall voters you know
because sakir stama doesn't uh doesn't
appeal to them very much either um so so
so there's all of that as for the left
there there's a slight hope there's a
slight hope that for the Tories that
something ghastly will happen to the
labor party as a consequence of the
Israel Gaza crisis where we have seen
starma under serious pressure uh and
there are a number of seats in the
country which are extremely problematic
for the labor party if it wishes to win
uh um an overall majority uh which are
either Muslim majority a couple of them
I think it's Bradford East uh or it
might be Bradford West and Birmingham
Hall green uh and there's another 30 or
40 where the Muslim vote is decisive and
whilst 62% of Muslims at the last
election voted on mass for the labor
party that was the last figure I saw was
down to
8% I mean that is enormous and you can
imagine the chaos for labor if uh genial
George Galloway decides to take up the
battle uh with respect and fight in
these seats and put candidates up for
respect in the various other seats where
the Muslims are are a large proportion
of the vote and we'll see a bit of that
uh I think in the London maral election
where I think Galloway May stand himself
so it's all it's all it's all very
interesting I the only Pro the problem
there electorally is that actually as
newspaper Proprietors and
editors well know the Israel Gaza crisis
balls the British public into submission
much as did Russia and Ukraine that's
why it's dropped down from the headlines
a little bit uh because actually it
doesn't have a great resonance with with
the voter with the reader uh or the
viewer uh that this isn't a story which
particularly grabs hold of them what
grabs hold of them is immigration uh it
is the cost of living and it is
inflation um but it it's but Foreign
Affairs never tends to impinge that much
I mean I think the the the other big
political theme it's almost the mirror
image of the theme of the Tories being
unable to move the dial is that it it's
clear the countryes out in love with the
Tories there's no question about that
it's over yeah as far as the country is
concerned but it's not gagging for k
starmer um you know they're not
desperate say oh if only K starmer was
in 10 Downing Street they don't feel
that way at all the way they did for
Tony Blair in 96 leading up to 987 which
is why I still have some doubts that
there'll be a huge labor majority I mean
there'll be a comfortable labor majority
and big enough for five years if that if
they want to go for five but it won't be
a blairite type uh Landslide on the
other hand they're not frightened of
karmer the way they were a bit
frightened of Neil kinck in uh 87 and
'92 they were frightened a little bit or
under or or just didn't rate Ed
millerand uh in 2015 they were
definitely frightened particularly up in
the red wall on of Jeremy Corbin they're
not frightened of karma like that they
see him as a relative safe pair ofans
Rod mention the cost of living which of
course domestically has been by far the
most important political issue and the
news I just come back from the stage the
news from America there is dire for the
Tories and the reason I say that is this
that the American economy is in far
better shape than the British economy
unemployment at record lows growth in
the third quarter was an annual rate of
4% living standards are rising again
interest rates are coming down inflation
is down to about 3% it's a pretty Rosy
economic scenario and the Biden
Administration is getting no credit
whatsoever and the reason for that is
the cost of living because although
inflation is down prices are still a lot
higher than they were and they've risen
by a lot more than wages so people still
feel bitter about the cost of living now
put that into a British context where
the economy is essentially stagnating
unlike America and the cost of living
crisis is still working its way through
and I think you look at 2024 and if
what's playing out in America and
harming the Biden Administration is
going to play out in Britain and harm
the sunik administration which is a much
worse economic tale to tell
anyway I I think that's right it's it's
quite interesting I was looking at the
at the figures I in a in a way this
reminds me and Andrew alluded to this
that there isn't the same degree of of
further for for I'm just trying to
imagine anyone being
fervent for Sak sta act it just doesn't
really work does it there's not the same
ferv for Sak sta that there was for Tony
Blair in a way it reminds me a little
bit of the of the 1964 general election
where you had a conservative party that
have been in power for uh 13 years uh I
suppose 13 years yes um with a
multiplicity of leaders Churchill Eden
McMillan Douglas Hume um and a public
which was sick of them and and I was
reading David kon's book uh about 62 to
65 in Great Britain U which was the time
when we built all these horrible
shopping centers and so on and the thing
which which bleeds through from that is
how within the conservative party they
simply couldn't um they couldn't shift
the dial at all that that the public had
registered a weariness and that
weariness wasn't going to go away and at
the time they weren't expecting Harold
Wilson particularly to be uh uh to be
the next prime minister it didn't really
matter it was whoever labor had who
wasn't actually you know mentally
impaired uh so it all reminds me a
little bit of that but if if as seems
almost inevitable as discussed that we
are Le we are heading towards Britain
having a center left I think we can call
Labor a center left party now A Center
left government Britain would then be
bucking the trend that we've seen in
2023 would it not and Andrew of um you
mentioned Trump earlier who seems to be
um now the favorite the bookie's
favorite to win the presidential
election next year we'll see about that
um but you know we have Javier m in
Argentina we have ger Wilders in Holland
we have the European elections coming up
next year in June where where the right
are supposed to to sweep the board um
the drift of global politics is going
right quite sharply is it
not yes it is and to that extent Britain
is out of kilter I think actually K
starma realizes that which is why he's
moved labor much more to the center than
I ever thought he would I mean I you
know when I interviewed him for the
leadership race way back in the just
before the pandemic in early 2020 I mean
he campaigned and won the leadership on
a Carbonite
Manifesto uh he had 10 pledges and all
of which came from the labor Manifesto
of
2019 we knew he would resile from that
over time but I never thought he would
go so far and then suddenly we have a
labor conference in which the Union flag
is flown proudly they sing the national
anthem God Save the King uh the you know
we going to be fiscally conservative uh
but we will protect defense spending we
uh the defense of the realm allies with
the United States all of that is now
part of the labor Mantra and I think
that is a kind of recognition that
although the country we are out of the
global political cycle and the to people
are fed out with the Tories he knows as
I say they're not gagging for him or for
labor and that he cannot afford to be
very far from the center left I mean
Rod's been writing with this and we'll
tell this more but there you know we
keep on thinking and it's some wishful
thinking for a number of the media that
the populous Revolt is coming to an end
uh and and every time we it's it's like
you know every 3 years The Economist
magazine identifies an African success
story and and within three weeks of that
article being published there's been a
coup and people are being slaughtered in
the street and is it's back to poverty
and penury and I and you know the forces
is look The Spectator had a very good
article I don't necessarily disagree
with it at all Leen could be the next
president of France you know as things
stand at the moment she probably have to
be a favorite the second biggest party
in Germany is now the afd uh Italy has a
populist prime minister the Sweden
Democrats not the social Democrats the
Sweden Democrats are now praying playing
a role in Sweden's government uh so you
see all of that beginning to happen and
that is before another recession comes
in and of course we have the Resurgence
of uh Donald Trump no matter how many
many lawsuits are thrown at him he just
seems to go from strength to strength
The Wall Street Journal poll which ends
the year chose him now four five points
ahead of Mr Biden uh and in five out of
the six swing States Wisconson being the
odd man out he's ahead in five out of
the six states that will determine the
election populism has not gone away and
I think Rod is better qualified to
explain that than I am
Andrew is absolutely right I mean it it
hasn't really not gone away it's simply
coming to fruition and has been doing so
for a period of around about 12 to 13
years perhaps even longer when you
remember pin forain in in the
Netherlands back in the early 2000s and
vams block people like that i' i' take a
you as to whether it's simply a
rightwing movement uh when you look at
uh for example one of the most recent
victories which was that of
uh I can't remember how you pronounce
his Sur name FICO is how you pronounce
it if he was Italian but he isn't he
Slovakian um feature perhaps uh that's a
Social Democratic party and it's
redistributive uh and but it's also very
very Hardline on immigration on Islam on
uh and on the various cultural
identitarian issues such like the Danish
Center left too no exactly uh and and
there are plenty of these parties around
when when you look at Europe and you're
saying it's the end of populism and K
Builders stops the poll in the
Netherlands and the Swiss decide that
they've had enough as well this is a
it's a revolt against neoliberalism and
that's very difficult for K Dharma to
deal with it's also obviously difficult
for Richie sun to deal with because
they're both birds of the same feather
when it comes to that particular
particular ideology uh and which is why
there is some Hunger for for people like
for us
who despite being basically a
thatcherite economically uh which is
certainly what he would claim to be um
uh there he still takes a tough line on
the social issues which are which are
the things which are annoying an awful
lot of people in Europe uh I mean he is
a thatcherite isn't he I mean I don't
think there's much getting away from
that the other thing I mean which is
quite interesting is when you look at
the opinion polls for the 2019 election
up here in the red wall seats there was
no so great aversion uh up here to the
economic policies which John McDonald
was suggesting uh would be in the labor
Manifesto uh which was basically
leftwing populism um and and taxing the
rich and and so on inheritance tax etc
etc etc uh the objection was always to
their lack of patriotism and to the
idiotic Foreigner foreign alignments
that that Jeremy Corbin had whether it
be with herass Venezuela Cuba Etc so
it's it's an anti-neoliberal thing yes I
think and I I think that is is what what
is driving it and it may be even in New
Zealand you know that strange hermit
Kingdom of New Zealand um and it may
well be that this often happens we are
out of step with the rest of Europe
partly because of our first pass
supposed system which is looking
increasingly
anachronistic uh but when it comes to
the next election I suspect it will
still be a neoliberal government which
wins I I I think right the a lot of the
media commentary which is based on
populism equals rightwing uh in
particular hard right view of the world
motivated Above All by anti-immigration
that's a very unsophisticated analysis
um the fact is it alludes to what Rod
was saying if you look at the economic
policies of Madame Leen and France and
the economic policies of melan Shong Mr
melen Shong the sort of Jeremy Corbin of
France there's not that much difference
they both want a big state they both
want uh State control of Industry they
both want uh a massive increase in the
minimum wage they are both
protectionists they're both anti- Euro
they are very much against neoliberal
economics and so on so the there is a
left and a right-wing populism comes
together here and and that needs to be
appreciated more because otherwise it's
just too easy to dismiss or it's just a
bunch of right wi Nutters uh is much
deeper than
that amazing to think isn't it that
Nicholas Duron uh was still first
minister of Scotland at the beginning of
this as I said uh we're in fee out times
all predictions can quickly be
[Music]
unfounded